do the birds make it back to chicago
what will happen to roos fortune will
three get his revenge for his family
keep watching because these are the
questions we still need answers to after
the ozark finale
for a while ruth claims victory over the
birds by taking control of the casino
she receives the rides that belong to
darlene snell as well as the family farm
seeing as it's darlene's land only feels
right for it to be run by locals it even
looks like she might get away with
killing hobby but alas camellia bullies
claire into telling her who killed her
son soon enough camellia ambushes ruth
outside her home and the cartel boss
shoots the fiery fan favorites in the
final hour this death introduces a major
question what will happen to roost's
possessions such as her stake in the
casino the snell farm and the lazio
motel though this might not seem
substantial in the grand scheme of
things the cartel has used a casino to
longer money despite root than rachel
garrison's desire to go clean it seems
likely that three langmore will gain the
rights to roost possessions unless she's
listed rachel as a benefactor but all of
this is based on speculation ruth was to
say the least wealthy before her demise
the show makes a point of spotlighting
this given where she's from and the fact
that her record is officially clean
before her death all of that money has
got to go somewhere
ruth convinces rachel to come back to
the missouri ozarks a tainted place that
has caused rachel an enormous amount of
pain now that ruth is dead rachel's plan
to work alongside her is kaput she might
decide to stay and make more money than
she ever has by working at the casino
but it also wouldn't be surprising if
rachel disappeared yet again out of fear
perhaps she baby zeke and three will
flee town together it's pretty much
anyone's guess
it's also not out of the question that
rachel might work for the birds that
prospective work could take place in
missouri chicago or somewhere else
entirely this is based solely on
speculation since her storyline ends
with her working at the casino on the
night of the byrd foundation gala before
ruth is killed the authorities would
have to suspect camellia of killing ruth
but that's yet another mystery ozark has
left in its wake
[Music]
with ruth's passing three is left as the
lone survivor of the langmore clan this
is a bit surprising considering he
doesn't receive as much screen time as
many other langmore characters and isn't
involved in the cartel or the snell
business
nevertheless three lives on it remains
to be seen what the most underrated
langmore will do now that ruth is dead
ruth presumably left three with enough
resources to flee the ozarks and try to
find a more peaceful life somewhere else
but really you never know
it's entirely possible that three will
go after the cartel once he gets a whiff
of who killed his cousin i can't say for
sure of course like most of these
questions this will remain up for debate
forever barring spin-off projects are
particularly revealing interviews with
the creators but here's what we do know
for certain three witnesses his entire
family die while the bird family is in
town whether or not those deaths are
linked to that clan that's the kind of
thing that makes an impression
for a while it seemed like the birds
might not make it out of this show alive
or if they did they would have sustained
irreparable damage after all marty has
to fill in as the head of the cartel in
mexico wendy checks herself into a
mental health facility in a bid to get
her kids back and charlotte and jonah
are on the verge of leaving with wendy's
father nathan big decision
take some time with it
but the birds managed to survive
separation a car crash and all the other
blood-soaked events that fled the series
and even managed to create a successful
foundation in the process thanks to
wendy they're now free from the cartel
and the fbi
when we last see the four triumphant
family members mel has evidence that
will link them to benton's death but
then jonah surprises him with a shotgun
classic jonah this scene and the entire
series end with the sound of a gun going
off presumably this comes from jonah
shooting mel viewers are faced with a
major question does the bird family
finally go back to chicago in the
aftermath of this bloodshed someone will
have to run the casino after roof's
passing but returning to chicago was
always the end game do they fulfill that
goal at last
the birds still have partial ownership
of the casino and it wouldn't be out of
the question for the cartel to continue
laundering money through it if they even
need to given their deal with the fbi
though of course this was always omar's
deal and it remains to be seen what
camellia plans on doing as the head of
the criminal organization
regardless this deal with the fbi is
supposed to clear the birds of any
charges as well as settle their debts
with a cartel it should be clear of
criminal activity from this point on but
since the bird foundation is still doing
business with claire who is doing
business with the cartel who knows what
lines will be crossed will the birds
stay clean hopefully that there's a
significant chance they won't the
cartels leader is now free to do
basically whatever she wants as long as
she continues to cooperate with the fbi
the series leaves the birds free and
clear from the authorities and the
cartel but they definitely might not
stay that way
in the final moments of ozark jonah
points a shotgun at mel the screen goes
black and the sound of a shot being
fired rings out this seems pretty
definitive but the ambiguity of the
moment sparks questions when shows or
movies don't clearly depict someone's
death it very well might mean that
they're not actually dead infamously the
sopranos ends on a similarly mysterious
cut to black leaving fans to wonder if
tony soprano meets his bloody end or not
ozark is less vague than this ending
though while tony soprano simply looks
up at a diner the sound of a gun being
fired on ozark is clear and jonah's
shotgun is the only visible weapon in
the scene it feels pretty safe to say
that jonah kills mel but since it's not
shown fans might always wonder what
happens and theorize accordingly perhaps
for example maya miller shows up and
fires her gun before jonah can pull the
trigger that might seem wild but it is
possible more likely than not mel meets
his demise at jonah's hands and the
birds are free to drive off into the
sunset it's a perfect ending to a
captivating crime drama full of
surprises but it's not the only ending
fans have to accept
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one